hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm gonna
answer a question from one of my
newsletter readers dieter who wrote in
saying Evan could you tell us about your
tough times right now you have a
beautiful life we always read about your
success into determination but how did
successful people like you come through
the tough times did you cry bake run hug
somebody thank you so much dieter a
great question and I think if you look
at any successful entrepreneur you have
to go through a whole bunch of tough
time fuel to get to the end goal and I
think it really helped me when I was
first getting started it was it was
tough in that was making autumn asst
takes and I wasn't really quite sure
what I wanted to do I knew I wanted to
help entrepreneurs and that was a
passion that I had but I didn't really
know what the model was and that's a big
challenge with a lot of entrepreneurs
face when you're starting up what's the
business model going to be right how you
gonna make money it's great that you're
helping people and you're following your
passion but to make it sustainable you
have to be able to make a living from it
right you have to be able to make enough
at least to get past survival so you're
paying your bills and then you can
continue to grow from there luckily for
me I had a lot of encouragement from
friends and family a lot i know a lot of
entrepreneurs don't have that you know
their family doesn't believe in them
they don't think there should be an
entrepreneur their friends are jealous
and you know put them down so I had a
lot of support around me which is great
but still it was really tough getting it
going you know the first the first part
of running a business is so hard because
you want things happen so badly and it
takes a while to get going and you put
so much work in I think a lot of
entrepreneurs just quit too soon you put
so much working at the beginning and you
invest so much time and energy and then
you don't see the immediate results and
then you quit and its really driving
force that you do something every single
day to make your business grow even just
a little bit and you eventually see that
momentum start to take shape and you'll
be able to build it into a successful
enterprise so what helped me was getting
feedback from
my customers my entrepreneurs were
getting the stuff that was creating and
just looking at the feedback and seeing
you know what I'm doing is actually
helping people and what I found swish at
the beginning most of the stuff that I
did at the start was offline it wasn't
to my website was through seminars
presentations to entrepreneur groups
sharing different you know topics
lessons that I had learned from my
success in business and what I found
interesting there was you go to an event
like that and I love speaking so you go
to a speaking event and you get all
jazzed up you get all excited you see
how you're helping people and you're in
that moment and you want to go home and
work like crazy to you know get to
another moment like that and then you
wake up the next day and it's gone and
how do you keep that momentum going you
know you don't want to just stay in bed
all day so how do you get the momentum
going between those highs and what I
found helpful was I made a actual little
presentation powerpoint that I watched
every day in the morning just for a
couple minutes that had some of the
quotes that people had left on their
feedback form so at the end of all the
presentations I did I had these little
feedback forms to ask people what they
thought and how can make it better and
the reviews that came back were awesome
you know people talked about how it
changed their life and how gave them
such helpful information are going to go
home and take action it's really
inspiring that's the part that I really
love about my business and so instead of
just having that high that one night I
put it together in that presentation it
was very simple just something I loaded
up every day and put a song to it and it
kind of got me going in the morning
caught me sinking you know I've been
able to help these people and I want to
do it again and I want to you know we
live that moment again and help more
people now or at the point within my
business where I get emails every day
from people who are saying how much they
really liked the video we made or the
newsletter or the content on our website
and even on YouTube getting the likes
and get in the comment is awesome that's
the stuff that makes you want to do more
of these videos and keeps me going every
day is your comments it's not so much
the money that comes in it's it's the
feeling that you're helping people and
how can they go through times that could
be tough I'm just having somebody who
believes in you it can be a really
powerful thing and so I found that
really helpful so in terms of I don't
know where you're at with your business
sounds like you're still kind of in the
earlies days I try to tap into the
feeling that you're helping people
because if you're motivated only by
money it makes it really hard to keep
going you know you're going to quit as
soon as it gets really really hard if
you're not really interested in what
you're doing and you don't feel like
you're helping people you can fight it
for so long you can fight it saying well
I'm going to make a lot of money doing
this but the money usually doesn't come
right away it comes after a lot a lot a
lot of hard work and effort so what I
would encourage you to do is think about
how you're really helping people and try
to remember those stories so think about
the best part you have in your business
whatever the the greatest high you've
had in your your company it was probably
something around helping somebody you
know really solve a frustration a
problem that they were facing and just
try to relive that moment every day or
every week as much as you can to get
yourself back into that zone of wanting
to get motivated and do a lot of work
and build this business up and tie back
into that vision that you have for the
company the second thing I thought
helpful was trying to have some bigger
bowl that I'm shooting towards so it
could be a numerical there could be a
lifestyle goal maybe you want to reach
the next X amount of dollars or you want
to be able to travel the world just just
try to imagine a lifestyle that you want
to go after and try to get to the point
of frustration so the first part is
getting motivated by knowing you're
helping people and seeing the feedback
that comes in the second one is getting
motivated by being frustrated with where
you are now if it's really painful your
situation now if you can make it
extremely painful you're more likely to
take action and to want to change your
situation so if your goal is to you know
go to Europe for a month or whatever it
is it doesn't have to be a massive goal
then think about what you're doing now
you know will what you're doing now help
you achieve that goal or not right if
you and if it's not then if you get
angry enough at it know if he's thinking
you know if I'm not working now
I'm not putting my best into it now I'm
never going to be able to achieve the
lifestyle that I want and that will
hopefully give you enough frustration to
take action and go out and do you know
what you need to do to grow your
business and I find that at least for me
at the beginning I had to reset every
day you know I could get motivated for
the day and then I wake up the next day
and you're back into your typical
patterns and I got to get motivated
again now luckily again for me I get a
lot of feedback every day that comes in
I just have to open up my email or look
at the comments on YouTube or Facebook
and see all the glowing review is not
getting me kick-started for what I want
to do for the day if you don't have that
yet then you know you want to start to
try to remember the best points and also
try to get frustrated at your current
situation and how you want to really
improve it and make it better so
hopefully not too long-winded an answer
to the question but a very important
question I hope it helped you dieter for
those are you watching again I'd love to
see the thumbs up come in and makes me
want to do more of these videos and I'd
love to hear we have to think about this
video or if you have a question for your
own company so if we leave in the
comments below it means a lot to me I
always read them every day and hopefully
you'll leave one if you really enjoyed
this video so thank you and I'll see you
on the next episode
you
you